In Final Destination, those who escaped fatal
accidents are now in a race against death
to find the signs and avoid the peril before
it arrives again.
The third film contains many references to
the iconic tragedy that kicked off the series,
Flight 180.
The roller coaster that crashes in the third
movie is called Devil’s Flight, a reference
to Alex seeing a luggage vehicle with the
devil’s number before boarding his flight
in the original.
Before getting on the ride, Wendy and Kevin
even line up in Row 6.
Ashley and Ashlyn go to Phoenix Tanning Salon,
whose phone number is listed as 570-555-0180.
And when Wendy and Kevin are on the way to
the fast food drive through, there’s a near-accident
with a truck from Penn State Towing and Recovery,
whose phone number after the area code is
also 555-0180.
Later on, Ian McKinley operated a forklift,
and in one close up we see that it’s UNIT
081, the mirror image of 180.
At the end, Wendy boards subway train 081,
and later sees it in the mirror as 180, just
like how we saw the backside of the sign of
Cafe Miro 81, reading as the number 180 during
the conclusion of the original.
To learn all the hidden secrets of Final Destination
3, including the HUGE CONSPIRACY REGARDING
THE SUBWAY SCENE AT THE END, stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome to Things You Missed.
This one has a roller coaster, and that’s
very exciting for me, so I want to hurry up
and get to that.
But for the third installment, the series
was handed back over to James Wong with a
G, who directed the first one.
I’d say he immediately got the series back
on track.
There’s irony in that sentence, I know.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
The opening credits bring back many of the
themes established, that I’ve discussed
in my episodes on the other movies.
We see a fortune teller, representing the
idea of psychic premonitions, and she has
tarot cards for Hope, Fate, The Devil and
Death.
We also see a painting of the devil and I
already mentioned the name of the coaster.
The second movie contained a lot of symbols
of luck, chance and fate all being linked,
and in this one we’re shown a spinning wheel
and a pinball game, both examples of carnival
games -- games of chance.
The pinball game has holes labeled as Luck,
Fate and Death respectively.
Another mural depicts “The Electric Sisters”
defying death in twin electric chairs.
The last two survivors in this movie end up
being Wendy and her sister, Julie.
There are a lot of pairs in this one in general.
We start off with two couples, Ashley and
Ashlyn are a pair.
We’ve got a pair of token goth characters,
MCR and Misery Business.
MCR’s real name is Ian McKinley, which pairs
with the name of the town.
Devil’s Flight seats in pairs, and there
are a pair of train related accidents: a roller
coaster train and a subway train.
That roller coaster is Devil’s Flight, which
was filmed on Playland Vancouver’s Corkscrew,
whose sign makes a cameo right here.
I find it hilarious that the coaster they
die on is a Vekoma coaster in North America,
because the manufacturer Vekoma doesn’t
have a great reputation on this continent.
They’re the ones who do all the Boomerang
coasters and have made some infamously rough
suspended looping coasters… or SLCs.
“Vekoma SLCs.
A horror of a word in the coaster community.”
“And one of the things I learned was how
horrible the Vekoma SLCs apparently are.”
“This has been a step by step guide to riding
Vekoma SLCs.
As you can see, we only got to step number
five, because everyone is dead.”
Devil’s Flight is not an SLC though, it’s
a model called Corkscrew with Bayerncurve.
Not particularly exciting, so for the movie,
more elements were added with CGI.
“Since we don’t have an actual roller
coaster that has a 360° loop, we’re recreating
it on a stage.”
This made it look less like a Vekoma and more
like an Arrow Dynamics looping coaster.
In particular, it looks a lot like Viper at
Six Flags Magic Mountain, but the theming
also reminds me of a different looping coaster
by Arrow Dynamics, Demon at Six Flags Great
America and California’s Great America,
which happens to be my first inverting roller
coaster.
Final Destination 3 introduced a new concept
where the signs about each character’s death
could be derived from the last photo that
person appeared in.
When we first meet the protagonist Wendy,
she’s taking pictures for her school’s
yearbook as her friends ride the freefall
ride, High Dive, but when she reviews the
snapshot, the letter V is off, making the
text say “High Die” which is still a better
title than Hellraiser 7.
The next line also foreshadows what’s about
to go down.
KEVIN: “That was intense man.
To feel how it would be to just crash and
burn like that.”
WENDY: “Yeah, yeah, maybe for you but our
lives are actually going somewhere.”
Wendy’s boyfriend also suggests that eating
junk food before going on Devil’s Flight
“might kill him.”
To this point, the opening disasters both
took place on May 13th.
We never do see the exact date of the roller
coaster accident, but I do think it makes sense
that it’s also May 13th because they’re
at the amusement park as part of their school’s
grad night, an event that would typically
take place in mid-May.
At the midway, Wendy photographs her classmate
Lewis trying a test of strength, but he’s
a little too strong and knocks the head clean
off.
This is a sign of how Death would get to him
during a different test of strength in his
football team’s weight room, where his head
ends up being crushed by a pair of weights.
Then, our characters head for Devil’s Flight.
JASON: “What’s wrong?”
WENDY: I was having that feeling like Déjà vu, you
know.”
No Wendy, you’ve got the wrong Vekoma coaster.
This is Devil’s Flight.
The voice of the titular devil is the voice
of the coroner from the first two movies,
William Bludworth.
I did a whole video explaining why he might
be here, so check that one out if you’re interested.
In line, the school’s super-super senior
Frankie is seen with a mudflap girl necklace,
an icon commonly associated with truckers,
which foreshadows his eventual death by runaway
truck.
At the end of the line, Jason and Kevin
both want the front row, so a coin flip ends
up deciding for them, once again tying the
idea of fate to luck and chance.
So they all get on the ride.
Who comes off a coaster looking like that?
The harnesses come down, and it’s clear
that Lewis is a coaster enthusiast.
“What’s up man, I’m good.”
We call that stapling.
“And almost nothing ruins a great ride more
than being stapled into your seat.”
There would be more signs, coincidences too
uncanny to be coincidences, easter eggs and
more after Devil’s Flight departed from
the station.
“Here we go!”
“Yeah!
Let’s do it baby!”
“We have to get off of here…”
In Final Destination 2, I pointed out how
the leaked transmission fluid kind of looked
like blood, and similar image is used when
the hydraulics get ruptured, giving the appearance
of dripping blood.
Before the train departs, this happens.
“Dare you to flash me those sweet sweet
titties when we go through the loop.”
Frankie, not only is that highly inappropriate,
but do you see these over the shoulder restraints?
How would they do that??
As the ride ascends the lift hill, you can
spot a nearby top spin ride called Hell’s
Gate, another one of the many demon references
I’ve pointed out in this franchise.
Jay and Carrie are on the first car that derails.
Lewis flies out of his harness, and MCR and
Misery Business are dropped from the top of
the loop where the train is stuck.
I mentioned the comparison to Demon earlier.
This part may be inspired by an incident that
occurred on Demon in 1998, where the train
got stuck on the top of one of the ride’s
two vertical loops and had to be evacuated
by the fire department.
Nobody died during this incident, but it still
gave birth to an urban legend about a kid
who supposedly didn’t meet the height requirement
and fell to his death when it got stuck; which
growing up in Chicagoland and going to the
park as a kid, I believed for several years.
When Wendy comes out of the vision, she freaks
out and causes 7 people including herself
to get off the ride.
Seven and thirteen come up a lot, the lucky
and unlucky numbers, and seven was the same
number of survivors from Flight 180.
In Wendy’s room there’s a picture of 7
stick figures holding hands.
Looks like it belongs in the movie Us.
Some time after the accident, Wendy clears
out her locker.
Her locker number is D-073, a sign about the
next pair of deaths that would occur when
Ashley and Ashlyn turn up the thermostat in
the tanning salon to 73°, causing the machines
to overheat and malfunction.
In the last movie I mentioned how Evan Lewis’s
Pontiac Firebird was one of the signals of
the apartment fire that led to his fate.
A phoenix is a mythological bird said to die
in a burst of flames and then it’s successor
is born from the ashes.
Ashley and Ashlyn are both names that be shortened
to Ash.
When referred to in plural, they are the Ashes,
and they both die in flames at Phoenix Tanning
Salon.
Ashlyn forgets her iPod, so they listen to
one of the CDs available at the salon, so
Ashley picks out Have A Nice Decade, Volume
6 -- there’s the devil’s number again.
The song they listen to is Love Rollercoaster.
Get it?
Because they were supposed to die on a roller
coaster?
So clever.
But like Demon, this song has its own ominous
urban legend attached to it.
The story goes that the scream heard during
the instrumental
🎵 Love Rollercoaster - Ohio Players 🎵
is actually the scream of a woman being murdered.
Other versions of the legend say it’s actually
audio of her falling off of a roller coaster.
While Ashley and Ashlyn are getting some color
for their funeral, Wendy misses a few signs
in her room, like a sticky note with writing
on it that says “Books To Die For.”
There’s also a monkey doll that’s hanging
onto the dresser in a similar way to how MCR
and Misery Business held onto the coaster
for dear life in her vision.
She notices the photo of Ash and Ash, and
the lens flare makes it look as if they are
burning in a fire, so she tries to call and
warn them.
ASHLEY: “Hello?”
WENDY: “Hey Ashley, it’s Wendy.”
ASHLEY: .Psyche!
Leave a message.”
“HA! GOT EEM! HA!”
At their funeral, the same exact music from
the Flight 180 memorial plays; it’s called
Hundered Grand by Pete Atherton.
I believe it was made specifically for the
movie.
After the ceremony, Wendy pulls out a photo
of regular Abraham Lincoln.
But basically Wendy says she believes her
photos from the night of the accident will
contain signs, just as these photos taken
before historical disasters seem to.
I know the whole images that precede unfortunate
events has become a meme at this point, but
I can assure you she did not print out these
photos for meme purposes.
They go to a fast food joint called Andy’s
to talk about it some more, and try to decipher
Frankie’s picture.
“Spongebob lives underwater.”
“It’s so sad that you know that.”
What?
Everyone knows that.
It’s right in the theme song.
“Who lives in a pineapple under the sea?
"Thank you so much Mr. Krabs. You're a life-saver. Go see Patrick."
While they’re analysing the picture, a Hice
Pale Ale truck passes behind them.
Those of you who saw my FD2 episode will remember
the drinking Hice Pale Ale truck driver during
Kimberly’s premonition of the accident,
a brand named after stunt coordinator Freddie
Hice.
We don’t know if this driver survived the
real version of the pile up, but I like to
think it’s the same guy.
This truck nearly gets Wendy and Kevin killed
when it blocks them in before the next accident.
Wendy first suspects something is wrong when
the order screen glitches out and the word
“control” disappears.
It’s essentially telling Wendy she’s losing
control of the situation.
Because as we know…
"I mean, you know I'm such a control freak."
"The real fear with these rides comes from the feeling of having no control."
"I'm usually such a control freak."
"...sense of having no control."
"Well it's nice to see that things haven't made you any less of a control freak."
Then the car radio starts playing Turn Around
Look At Me, originally by Glen Campbell.
🎵 There is someone walking behind you… 🎵
A clue that the danger is going to come from
behind them.
The first pair of deaths came during the song
“Love Rollercoaster” and this one would
have a coaster reference as well.
The runaway truck that would eventually take
out Frankie is from Rolling Thunder Moving
and Storage.
Rolling Thunder is fairly common roller coaster
name, but the biggest Rolling Thunder was
the one at Six Flags Great Adventure.
In 1981, a park employee who failed to secure
the safety bar fell to his death during a
test run.
The truck barrels towards the Andy’s drive
through after it’s left unattended and rolls
down a big hill, converting potential energy
into kinetic energy, like a roller coaster.
“ A roller coaster is just elemental physics.
A conversion of potential energy to kinetic
energy.”
The truck also features blue white and red
stripes, the colors of the French flag that
are seen in stripes on the Volée Flight 180
aircraft, the bus that struck Terry Chaney,
and the train that ended Billy Hitchcock.
With just over half of the Devil’s Flight
survivors remaining, Wendy and Kevin would
try to decipher the rest of the photos, and
in them, we can find even more Things You Missed.
As they review the remaining photos from the
night of the accident, Wendy and Kevin look
for any potential clues about the next death.
Wendy had already seen Jason’s photo, where
it looks like his head is about to be struck
by a roller coaster.
I’ve got a similar photo from 2017, so if
anyone knows how I’m gonna die, please get
in contact.
She also found Frankie’s picture where his
head looks like it could be hit by a spinning
fan-blade that looks similar to the motor
that took him out not long ago.
They figure that the next victim will be Lewis,
but they struggle to determine the cause of
death.
They eventually decide that this Swirling
Dervish guy could represent Lewis’s football
team and the guy flexing his muscles might
be a sign that the accident occurs in the
weight room.
They fail to consider how the Sultan’s scimitars
play into the equation.
However, when they get there they do discover
a pair of swords, along with the motivational
text: “what doesn’t kill you makes you
stronger,” a callback to Kevin’s line
before going on Devil’s Flight.
JASON: "Before riding Devil's Flight? Yeah, that might kill me."
KEVIN: “No!
What doesn't kill you makes you stronger,
man.”
There’s also a callback to the first movie.
You may remember during Tod’s accident there
was nearly a moment where he could have been
electrocuted when he plugs in the radio just
before the leaked water reached his feet.
This time, the leak comes from the water fountain,
and the radio is a boombox.
Instead of playing Rocky Mountain High, the
song of choice is appropriately titled “Killing
Time” by Hed Planet Earth.
If Final Destination 3 was made today, maybe
they would have just done a cover of Rocky
Mountain High called Rocky Mountain Construction.
This seems like as good a time as any to bring
up constant use of water as part of Death’s
designs.
Almost all the deaths in the last two movies
had water or liquid involved in some way and
we see it again here: the leaked hydraulic
fluid on the ride, the dripping beverage at
the tanning salon, this water fountain at
the gym and the spilled All Purpose Glass
Cleaner that the forklift slipped on at the
hardware store.
After being unable to save Lewis, they go
back to the car and they’re now just wearing
Sultan’s merch?
Sure, they just saw a guy’s head explode
but who could resist hitting the gift shop
on the way out?
I guess there is a valid reason, since their
clothes got spattered in Lewis’s guts, but
still seems kind of funny.
Then they have this moment together, please
do not smash your best friend’s girl a week
after his death my dude.
OK good.
They leave.
Another running gag that I brought up when
covering the first two Final Destinations
was that many of the characters were named
after classic horror movie icons.
This time we had many more.
Wendy and Julie Christensen were named after
Benjamin Christensen; Kevin Fischer after
Terrence Fischer, Jason Wise perhaps named
after Robert Wise who made the original The
Haunting, Carrie Dreyer after Carl Theodore
Dreyer (she may also be related to Blake Dreyer
from Flight 180, Lewis Romero after George
A Romero, Ashley Freund after Karl Freund,
Ashlyn Halperin after Victor Halperin and
the two cops Clark and Polanski, who are named
after Bob Clark and Roman Polanski.
There’s also a security guy named Bludworth,
a reference to the coroner from the previous
movies, William Bludworth.
Ian and Erin also have nicknames for each
other, Zip and Pip...
ERIN: "Zip? It's Pip. Have you cut those plywood orders yet?"
...which are the names of these two in the 1932 horror classic: Freaks,
kind of a self-aware joke about them being
the gothic pair.
There’s also a new theme introduced in this
one, where there’s a common nomenclature
for all the exits on the subway, but I’ll
get to that a little bit later on in the video.
Next up on Death’s hitlist is our good friends
Misery Business and MCR, who never told us
what he does for a living.
Despite the nickname I’ve given him, he
doesn’t work in a cubicle, but rather, at
a hardware store, which happens to be filled
with a lot of… not so conventional weapons.
If we take a look at the photo for these two, there
are a couple of things to note.
The picture is taken at the midway, and the
lettering overhead says “Test Your Skill”,
but you’ll notice that the letter S is kind
of receded into the dark, and the result is
just the word KILL.
These things that are pointed down at him
are the same shape as the giant Tricentennial
sign that crushes him at the end of the movie.
The photo also shows him holding a gun up
to his girlfriend’s face.
He doesn’t end up being the one to pull
the trigger on her, but it is his nail gun
that fires off and ultimately does her in,
and she passes on while holding her hand
up in the same pose that she does in the image.
In the first movie, there were constant allusions
to France, and more specifically, people who
passed away in France, and Ian’s mockery
of the supposed death signals makes reference
to that.
“How come when a guy dies of a plain heart
attack, no one goes like, ‘Oh wow, he was
eating french toast, when Princess Diana died
in Paris, and then he saw the funeral on TV
and now he’s dead.”
Before I get on to the last two disaster scenes
of the movie, I want to circle back to something
I touched on earlier: luck, chance and fate.
I’ve already gone over several examples
of references to luck and characters having
lucky charms, but there are actually even
more that are associated with these three
characters that make it to the end.
Wendy’s sister Julie has a bracelet given
to her by her grandmother, and in one line
we learn that she actually considers it to be a
good luck charm.
“Wen, so I’m meeting some guys at that
Centennial things and I could really use my
good luck… bracelet...”
When she wakes up, she realizes that her sister
is in danger, so she rushes to the tri-centennial
to try to save her.
On the way, she crosses paths with…
Bloody hell it’s Sirius Black!
No wait, it’s just a wolf.
But wolves are considered to be a symbol of
good luck in Mongolian folklore.
Then at the festival, we see a blacksmith
smelting an iron horseshoe, which, as I mentioned
when I talked about FD2, is another good luck
charm.
Then, briefly skipping ahead to the final
scene on the train, there's a poster for Discovery
State Lottery, advertising a potential lucky
payday, a scratch card lotto with the text:
this could be your lucky day, and in Wendy’s
final vision, she breaks her leg -- the phrase
‘break a leg’ is another way of saying
good luck.
At the beginning of the tri-centennial celebration
scene, we’re given a sort of quick recap
of all the disasters so far.
We’re shown a horseback rider to represent
the riders of the roller coaster; a fiery
grill to represent the burning girls in the
tanning salon; we cut to Wendy hearing the
song that played before Frankie’s demise,
we see some colonial men marching with swords
to represent the swords that destroyed the
weight machine that offed Lewis, and MCR shows
up, it was his nail gun that took out Erin.
For some reason he’s acting like iDubbbz.
“Hey, I’m just celebrating our town’s
tri-centennial.”
“What a day!
What a lovely day!”
Kevin chases about a couple of kids with sparklers
in a scene very reminiscent of Clear at the
gas station in Final Destination 2, and MCR suffers a fate that looked almost exactly
like that of Tim Carpenter in that same movie.
I just don’t get why neither of them don't try
to move.
I guess he really just wanted to go headfirst
for Halos.
You know he may have had a bulletproof heart,
but he most certainly didn’t have signproof
head.
Like the FD1 finale in Paris, the subway scene
would be the grand finale of Final Destination
3, and it holds more secrets than any other
scene so far in the franchise.
Five months after the main events of the movie,
Wendy is in college, thinking that her, her
sister and Kevin are now safe from Death’s
onslaught.
Just as the opening took place on a roller
coaster train, the finale would go down on
a subway train.
The advertisements plastered upon the walls
and ceiling are looming reminders of the tragedies
that befell Wendy’s classmates just that
summer.
We see the Slushee ad, the same forbidden
drink that Ashley snuck into the tanning room,
which ultimately dripped into the machinery
and caused their disaster.
Of course, I already mentioned the inclusion
of the Phoenix Tanning Company.
There’s a promo for Build It.
This is the hardware store where Misery Business
wasn’t careful enough and uh… became a
misguided ghost.
Then there’s one for Andy’s, the fast
food drive through where Frankie drove in,
but not out.
Then there’s Montgomery and Glick.
This one’s actually a real company, and
I wouldn’t be surprised if this is the tax
firm of choice for some of the crew.
But the important part to note here, is the
slogan.
“There’s no escaping death and taxes.”
The saying usually goes “there are only
two certainties in life, death and taxes,”
so the “no escape” thing is a nice Final
Destination twist on the old phrase.
Another poster advertises a product called
Cheez-y-Chums, which is made by Wohlgemuth
Fine Foods.
That’s a reference to Final Destination
3’s art director, Tony Wohlgemuth.
There’s also a new product called Blaze
Unsweetened something, perhaps another clue
of the fiery crash that would soon occur.
The one I find to be the most interesting
though, is the rail map.
I noticed something was up when I heard this.
Roll it.
“This is Booth Street.
Next stop is Oswald.
End of the line.
Next stop is the end of the line.”
Booth and Oswald are both assassins of American
presidents.
John Wilkes Booth is the guy who shot Regular
Abraham Lincoln, as Wendy explained earlier
in the movie, and Lee Harvey Oswald is the
man believed to have sniped John F Keneddy.
That got me thinking about the rail map here.
We see a stop at Ruby Drive.
Jack Ruby is the guy that killed Lee Harvey
Oswald 2 days later in retaliation.
The next stop is McVeigh.
Timothy McVeigh was responsible for the Oklahoma
City bombings in 1995.
When he was arrested, he was wearing a t-shirt
with a picture of Abraham Lincoln on it and the
words sic semper tyrannis -- allegedly the
same words that John Wilkes Booth shouted
in the Ford Theater before executing Lincoln.
Then there’s 63rd Street.
John F Kennedy was assassinated in 1963.
After that, there’s Hidell.
Hidell was the alias used by Lee Harvey Oswald
when he bought the rifle used to fire upon
John F Kennedy.
On the other side of the map, starting with
the orange line, is another stop is called
Jim Jones.
This was a cult leader who organized a major
deadly crime in Jonestown, Guyana.
One of the other stops is called Jonestown
Transfer.
The next stop on orange looks like is says
Hinkey.
This could be a misspelling of the surname
of George Warren Hickey Jr., the secret service
agent who was in the car behind John F Kennedy
the day he was shot.
Some conspiracy theorists believe Hickey Jr.
is actually the one who took out Kennedy.
The orange line ends at Hubbard.
James Hubbard was a murderer from Alabama
in the 70s.
There are a couple other stops on the other
side of the orange line that are a little
harder to make out.
It looks like this one says Manchester, a
reference to Trevor Hardy, and English killer
who was nicknamed The Beast of Manchester;
and this one says Berkowitz.
That would be David Berkowitz, the man responsible
for several shooting in 1976 New York.
Moving over to the green line, there’s Bundy.
That’s named after Ted Bundy, one of the
biggest serial criminals in American history.
I already mentioned Jonestown Transfer, so
next up is Czolgosz.
Now I have to admit, at first I thought this
guy was pretty cool for having the letters
CZ at the beginning of his name, but then I found out that
he’s not as cool as me, because Leon Czolgosz
was the assassin of American president William
McKinley.
That’s when it all clicked for me, cause
when you watch Final Destination 3, one name
you’ll hear over and over is McKinley.
Their town is named McKinley, there’s also
a McKinley street on the subway map, the theme
park was McKinley park, the school was McKinley
high and MCR’s real name was Ian McKinley.
With this in mind, I thought back to the first
movie and started making even more connections.
Mt. Abraham, New York and Mt. Abraham High
School -- both were probably named for Abraham
Lincoln.
Flight 180 also took off out of JFK airport.
The license plate of Carter’s car had the
letters RFK.
That stands for Robert F Kennedy, JFK’s
brother who was also assassinated.
The next green line stop is Carcano, a reference
to the type of rifle Lee Harvey Oswald used.
After that is Gein.
Ed Gein.
The butcher of Plainfield, Wisconsin.
Applewhite.
That’s Marshall Applewhite, another cult
leader who did horrible stuff and claimed
39 lives.
Finally we have the Red line.
And that starts with Earl Way, a reference
to James Earl Ray, the man who took out Martin
Luther King Jr.
Next stop.
Koresh.
Another cult leader.
This one’s from Texas.
Really bad stuff.
At least 20 victims.
Next stop.
Mambro.
Franchesca Mambro was Italian bomber who took
96 victims in Rome in 1980.
Next stop: Chapman.
Mark David Chapman isn’t just a banger of
a Mindless Self Indulgence song, he was another
assassin from Texas whose jealousy of the
Beatles went too far and he unfortunately
ended the life of John Lennon.
There are a lot of crazy theories about secret
messages hidden in Beatles songs during the
aftermath of this.
I’m not gonna get into it in this video,
but I will just point out that Love Rollercoaster
isn’t the only song referenced by this movie
with an urban legend behind it.
As long as I’m on the topic of dead rock
stars here, I’m just gonna point out that
Wendy has a bobblehead of Joey Ramone in her
room, so maybe that ties into this somehow
as well.
And my final thing that I’d like to point
out is the end credits music.
After the roller coaster crash, we heard the
song Love Rollercoaster.
And after the train crash to end the movie,
the credits rolled accompanied by a cover
of the song “Love Train”.
If you’re familiar with this song, you may
know the original artist is The O’Jays,
which gives us one more alleged killer reference,
as OJ Simpson was suspected of taking out
his wife in 1994.
Click the video on the left for more even
more Things You Missed in the Final Destination
franchise.
Coming up next, I’ll be covering movies
4 and 5, so make sure you don’t miss it
by subscribing to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, RING the deathbell to select all
notifications, and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you want to beat death, use a facemask
and social distancing.
PLEASE.